blade smiths congratulations you've made
it to the final round of this
competition now it's time for you to go
back to your home forges and recreate
this iconic weapon from history
a booge
good luck blade smiths we'll see you in
four days
yeah we're going to you buddy
so it's day one i'm back home in
evansville indiana and i'm ready to get
started on this booge build
i'm working on the dagger first i think
it's the easiest thing to warm up and
start with
i really gotta watch my dimensions this
dagger as i'm forging it i'm keeping in
mind that where the ricasso and the
transition from the blade to the tang is
i gotta make sure i'm not too wide to go
inside the handle and the pipe so i
gotta make sure i'm not too narrow where
this thing's gonna rattle around so i
really have a tight window that i need
to fit in good enough for now
i made some great progress but i've got
a lot to do it's freaking me out
[Music]
it's day one i'm here at the home forge
i'm getting warm in here man it's
freezing i'm making a booge it's uh it's
a little bit bougie i would say a little
bourgeois
it's not only a piece for warfare but
it's a really artistic expression of
whoever's carrying it
i'm thinking of doing some sand maize so
sandwiching it with a mild steel that'll
just make it that much more
tough i chose san mai to really bring
the most out of these two different
types of steels the the mild steel is
very tough and can take a lot of bending
the cracking while the hardened 5160 in
the center
is just coming down where i need it
along the edge see to get the the billet
down to more manageable size
i hot cut off the excess and as i'm hot
cutting you know putting a lot of
stresses on those welds and one of the
the pieces of mild steel is wanting to
kind of rip away
that's pretty bad news
from hot cutting it all the stresses on
it found a weak point right there
so in order to fix that delamination i
got a few more tries and forge welding
it up with the thickness that i have
if i get too thin then it's a lost cause
i just hope i can make this work
not only is it day two but it is also my
28th birthday
creating a challenge weapon in my home
shop that's a pretty cool birthday
present today i'm going to start forging
the larger blade of the bouge
so what i'm trying to do is split this
tang off of here
and i've got to form my clip point
then i can draw my length out and that
shape will follow and then i can start
getting that swoop that i need for that
booge look
time to get this bad boy quenched this
is the moment that i really need to nail
and i am praying that this thing's gonna
stay straight
i pull it out
[Laughter]
ah that thing is harder than nine
dollars with the jawbreakers and
straight as an arrow man
pretty good birthday
it's day two and i'm looking at the
blade and i'm not a hundred percent on
the laminations on the sand my
so
it's seeming to make the best sense just
to scrap it and start over
i'm gonna use a big old piece of leaf
spring and see what i can do a second
time around
starting over with the 5160 mono steel
blade time is really at a premium i may
not finish
so it's the start of day three
i have to start putting a lot of puzzle
pieces together and do a lot of
fabrication 60s too hard i think i need
a tip of this some more
a little hard for my liking for what
it's going to be doing so i'll soften it
some more
trying to make sure that my blade gets
up to temperature relieves stress so
that me i've got a nice flexible yet
strong blade
if i don't get these blades softened and
more flexible they're more likely to
snap right now they're very brittle if i
heat up the very end
and keep heating up the end the heat
will travel and draw the temper all the
way down and it's the best i can do
right now
i've got my dagger tempered i can put my
handle on then i'll slide my socket on
weld that beast up and we're ready to go
it fits right in there
my blade is completely assembled it's
not pretty but it would perform i think
it's ready to roll man
so yesterday i forged out the blade of
my bouge i forged out the stiletto
and got around to heat treating the
bougie blade
today i have to heat treat the stiletto
heat treating a stiletto is going to be
a little tricky because there's zero
room for warpage this thing needs to be
dead straight to be able to fit in that
handle if it's not i mean it could hang
up in there it might not even come out
or just rub against the interior wall
and dull the blade
so that was the moment of truth
yeah it looks great it looks perfectly
straight
it's time to start chiseling it the
elephant head into the bolster now
i'm choosing to put an elephant on my
booge because that was the traditional
creature they that add onto it and i'd
really like to honor the the culture and
the these amazing smiths who are
creating this
there we go
so the weapon as a whole i think is
becoming a beautiful piece
joe benton welcome back to the forge you
fellas have had four days at your home
forges to work on your booge with hidden
stiletto blade joe how did it go
it went well
my blade's made out of leaf spring got a
coil spring stiletto
and some etched design work on there
what about you ben i feel like my build
went well
my blade's out of 5160
and my stiletto is 1084. it was a tough
build but i feel great about it well
gentlemen only one of you can be the
forest of fire champion and to determine
which one of you it will be it's time to
test them there will be a strength test
of sharpness test and up first the kill
test doug
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test
your boujas look beautiful but are they
deadly well to find that out i will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
two
big carcasses
joey up first ready i'm ready let's do
this
my heart's racing my knees are rattling
i just feel like anything can happen
[Music]
[Music]
in the office
[Music]
[Music]
first up this blade
is sharp
the point is easy enough to get into the
carcass and snatching the way out
it's got a great feel to it
nice stiletto
there's even a handle that you put on
this so it gives a nice look to it
overall sir
this boosh
we'll keel
thanks doug
all right benton
are you ready to ham it up ready to rock
and roll let's do this
joe's bouge performed incredibly it
split that pig in half
and now it's my turn and i'm terrified
i've never made this style of weapon
before i've never been able to test this
kind of construction i just don't know
how it's gonna hold up
[Music]
oh
man
sorry man
it's a big piece of shrapnel
damn it
well benton
one of the things i like about this you
put on the leather it gave me a very
nice area to hold on to and it's ovoid i
can tell where the edge is
but
the obvious happened
it's a coarse green structure here i
should have normalized that tang much
better than i did but when you're
grinding away long days in the shop
during this challenge and you're just
focused on the finish line it's easy to
overlook some things and obviously i did
well ben any warrior knows that if you
leave a piece of shrapnel that big in a
target it's deadly however a warrior
also knows that his weapon needs to be
strong and your blade has suffered a
catastrophic failure in our very first
test
and therefore you cannot move forward in
this competition
come on brother
you did a great job man
i feel pretty bummed but this challenge
has been both very difficult and
invigorating at the same time i've made
things that i've never made before
and i've overcome some challenges that
i've never had to face before so overall
it was a great experience
joe your blade is sharp deadly and
strong and you are the new forged and
fire champion and that's a title that
comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars good job
how you feel right now it's a little
surreal i'm a forge to fire champion
i won but you know it'd have been nice
to win after the three tests but this
has been a totally unique opportunity
it's really a big affirmation of my
abilities yeah it's amazing
you